[Music]
kate middleton is pretty in pink in
belize the duchess of cambridge dazzles
in a shimmery bright pink floor-length
gown designed by the vampire's wife and
accessorizes her look with oversized
silver circular earrings and a white and
black embroidered clutch
that's her hubby prince william by her
side looking quite dapper himself
sporting a navy jacket and chino pants
[Music]
the couple's trip to belize is an
official one for the royals it's all in
honor of queen elizabeth ii platinum
jubilee
here they are arriving at a special
reception at the mayan ruins the duke
gave a speech thanking the people for
their hospitality and for honoring his
grandparents the queen and the late
prince philip i'm honored to convey the
very warmest wishes from my grandmother
the queen of belize
on the occasion of her platinum jubilee
she always speaks so fondly of her
visits to belize
which of course included a memorable
stop here at kahal pech in 1994.
william also noted the couple's three
children prince george princess
charlotte and prince louis were rather
jealous they did not get to join their
parents on this getaway and it seems the
royals are enjoying their alone time
together
that's caden williams showing off their
dance moves while visiting with the
garfuna community in hopkins on monday
[Applause]
yeah the prince and his dance partner 57
year old local laura cacho totally took
over the floor
and it turns out laura loved it telling
royal reporters that william is a good
dancer adding that he shook his waist to
the music and had beautiful rhythm as
for kate she knows how to get down too
[Music]
the mom of three shows she can do it all
bringing her fashion a game once again
rocking a blue tory burch dress earrings
and wedge heels people respect her they
look up to her they admire her she's
very much seen as a role model and i
think certainly over the last 18 months
we've seen more of the real kate the
person behind the title the hrh duchess
of
cambridge then we that we have done
actually ever we're seeing the duchess
in a very different light i think there
is a new confidence about her i think
that comes with age she is now 40 she is
very confident poised self-assured woman
and with a great sense of humour a lot
of talent some of which we're only just
learning about and that confidence kate
has is something we'll continue to enjoy
seeing whether displayed through her
style or those dance moves
[Music]